So based on the characteristics of this
story which kind of Asian do you think
he is oh he's Asian Chinese yeah
gambling Chinese yeah he's Chinese
Gambler man he's Chinese in China yeah
[Music]
there's a four-year-old girl she gets
kidnapped for ransom okay not good the
kidnapper tells her mother that she's
got to pay seventy thousand dollars
within three days to get the girl back
oh [__] turns out the mom finds out who
the kidnapper is it's family it's the
girl it's family that amount of money is
too specific the kidnapper is her own
dad do it he kidnapped the granddaughter
she finds out who it is but he still
says he's still gotta pay I don't care
if you know what to get her back or I
kill her so she didn't recognize her own
father's name like she did that's why
she found out who he was oh she's like
hi Dad yeah
I don't even know who that is
I'm not your dad honey yeah so it turns
out that this grandfather is a gambling
addict oh and in order to get this money
he kidnapped his own granddaughter to
try to get the money from the mom but
then the mom just calls the cops the
cops arrest the guy and it's over with
but do you think you try to ask nicely
first and he goes I just need one more
he goes you do this too many times dad
fine and he goes
we have your daughter Dad I know it's
you you son of a [__] calls back 15
minutes later based on the
characteristics of the story which kind
of Asian do you think he is oh he's
Asian Chinese yeah
gambling ass Chinese yeah Chinese dude
yeah he's Chinese
Chinese Gambler man he's Chinese in
China yeah you know my uh he went to
Macau my ex-girlfriend in high school
her mom was the gambling addict and
gambled away like two houses
and also her older brother's uh college
fund oh oh my God she couldn't stop was
she ever up does it seem like I don't
think so she was up two houses at a
college fund at one point and it was
like she's always like um has to keep
this like whole picture of Lies up
so you don't she doesn't even know what
her relationship with her mom really is
because everything's so like money and
numbers based stuff like oh yeah oh yeah
don't worry I got you it's like and then
they'll be like oh but can I get it that
like I'll take you out to eat and then
later she's like it's because she like
will give a little bit so that later
she's like oh can I get a thousand
actually and it's just always like the
whole relationship is like a
manipulation you know so he's just like
wait is my mom being genuine right now
or she just needs money so everything
feels
like like a what's the word like
ingenuine yeah crazy tradition well it's
crazy because a lot of Asians have like
a history of gambling yeah they'll
they'll be so cheap on everything right
save here yeah [__] get the cheapest
thing there and then when they walk into
a casino they can't control any of that
[__] and what's crazy is like the mom
will know it so the final house that
they got she was like just put it under
just just the dad's name just put under
dad's name oh she knows that like if
it's underwear what's the dad doing
during this whole time they're all in
the casino business they're all like but
can we talk about this though that no
one really talks about when you win big
it's almost worth all the other [__]
it's almost worth it it's a run that's
why I don't gamble because I know if I
hit that jackpot it's just like
it's in my DNA yeah so you've never
gambled I've gambled a little bit but I
just know like the amount of money I win
that's like five or six bucks what are
you playing last time you guys taught me
how to play craps Anthony taught me how
to play craps craps in the group though
it's so [__] nothing get up I don't
want to brag but I won 37 I lost 300 in
like five minutes but with that 37
dollars
I I felt like I was a man on the mission
dude I was I just felt like a big shot
do your mom or dad have gambling
Tendencies at all no it doesn't have in
your family so it's not really in the
DNA or my Chinese DNA maybe I watched
you lose 135 yeah on our Super Bowl bet
yeah that was heartbreaking I was pissed
have you seen how like Morongo or Paula
they like uh have free transportation to
the casino from wherever you are just to
get you there because there's a lot of
old Asian people that can can't drive
themselves yeah so they like set up
these like pick up things that put you
on a bus and like bring you all the way
I'll take you to Vegas oh wow yeah like
those Services where it's like yeah just
come just come we'll take care of
everything damn my grandma's obsessed
with Barona what's that Barona Casino
yeah it's in San Diego
obsessed she loves to play The Wizard of
Oz slot machine but she's not like
massively down right
I mean I I don't really know because you
know some old people just like playing
but they're not even trying to like
spend that much anyway yeah I like to
think it's that yeah I mean I don't know
like I don't we really don't know if
they're going into the savings and all
that either because they're so addicted
and bored pensions yeah yeah we I have
uh um my grandpa who lost like a
apartment in like two homes two homes
yeah he came from a uh a wealthy family
that he inherited he was the firstborn
son and then um my grandma came from a
wealthy family too but then
um I think the last my mom told me like
the last stretch was when they lost the
house that they were living in is when
my grandma left him and then that's when
um her dad my great grandpa built her a
separate house on their like several
acre lot and then they lived there
uh and then my mom didn't really see her
dad anymore after that Jesus yeah yeah
but because of that I'm like oh there's
that gambling Gene in my and that's
probably why I like doing big things
like you know I had exciting moves I had
a buddy who had to support his mom's
gambling addiction it was pretty sad
because he he went to support it he had
to because like she she was like
massively addicted and then he uh would
use a lot of his money to like fill the
gaps of things that she wouldn't be able
to pay for from again oh sure like for
her living yeah it's crazy it's
literally like
um almost like a drug addiction it is
but the thing is there's no substance
abuse the crazy crap I show like the
type of stories that my my
ex-girlfriend's mom would fabricate of
like why she has to stay at work later
coming home later like it just sounds
like meth head Behavior you know why she
needs to borrow money why Allison she
has this car or why not she has to sell
the car it's just like this constant
just stories and it's almost like dude
are you on drugs but she's just addicted
too funny they're dopamine fiends bro
yeah like crazy it is a rush though 100
it's a sick rush it was a [__] rock
but it hits bro yes sir
oh the lights they know what they're
doing bro I've never had that happen
before I've never well I think the worst
thing that can happen to you gambling is
winning yeah yeah well it just it just
depends on your your own uh method of
risk taking though or chasing losses
right yeah chasing losses I remember
being in a casino and my girlfriend was
like had like Rich parents and [__] and
I saw him in the in the High Roller part
of the slots and he likes to play high
roller and he would play hard he would
like play like he'd put like 30 grand
down and I remember just walking up to a
machine I was like that one I walked up
I put in a hundred dollars which was
like huge for me back then put a hundred
dollars
and then it turned into 1200 and I just
hit the print thing so fast because I
was like that's my rent I'm like I'm out
of here [__] yeah yeah but I was like
this is what I'm willing to bet while
I'm in Vegas I might as well just take a
shot on one of the bigger ones because
I'm seeing this cat I'm like standing
behind him for like 35 minutes I'm just
watching him like he'll win like five
grand two grand one grand 500 bucks and
then lose the same amount like on the on
the downswing if I were you I would have
walked over to the roulette table and
put it on black see I just walked right
into the cashier and I got paid 1200.
boom on black
24 and then what or use it all or
[__] double green or whatever
Jordan has a massive gambling addiction
too yeah I think he still does yeah
right is he up or down well you think
about you think about like one of the
best winners of all time right and like
for him to get
addicted to gambling it's like oh it's
purely in that dopamine hit it's truly
that Rush of just waiting to see if you
could make that I think it's meant for
people who like fighting against odds
like being that special like knowing
that I am in a statistical disadvantage
but like I want to be a part of that 10
and then so highly competitive people
can be addicted and if you have no
skills to to have an outlet like Michael
Jordan or whatever then you kind of fall
into that like I'm sure X's mom like if
she had other methods of expressing that
risk I think yeah that's true you guys
remember yeah yeah remember the Jordan
DOC The Last Dance we all like that's so
good so the the director he was saying
that he was hanging with Jordan a lot
right and he said that um Jordan when
they got into a car to just go to a
place where they were gonna film
something
Jordan's like all right let's do a BET
right now even me he's like
um the over under on how many pairs of
Jordans we see on the street on the way
there yeah and like that's how the guy
is dialed in to like let's bet like
shoes like oh I see Jordan like they're
playing slug bug but putting money on
exactly but putting money on it to see
his own products yeah constantly
competing constantly competing so
interesting yeah rolling dice with the
security guy at the [__] stadiums you
know what I mean but I think that's what
makes a winner though like you got to be
obsessed about winning competitive yeah
that also makes a loser sometimes though
right it can't depends on yeah what you
value You Gotta Lose to Win though baby
you got to learn how to I see you know
people gambling problems too that like
they're like stealing from their like
significant others you know what I mean
like oh yeah literally taking petty cash
and change or like finding money and
just grabbing it something go out late
at night not come home for like two
three days yeah my brother-in-law did
that to me and Nikki he like raided our
coin jar and he was like addicted to
drugs at the time thankfully he's in
but yeah he was like you know and I I
knew I was like around enough kids in
San Diego who did drugs I was like this
guy's [__] high and I think that the
family was just so
um like they love the guy so much and
like they didn't want to think he was
doing bad things but it was like pretty
obvious to me and Nikki that he was
doing drugs but then like the parents
were like nah nah like there's no way he
wouldn't do it and all that kind of [__]
but yeah he rated our coin charge just
completely him and his friend came in
took every quarter dime nickel we had
and they didn't think no one would find
out bailed yeah exactly and we knew our
coin jar was rated because we did
laundry with that [__] and it's like how
come it's nothing but pennies and
nickels left nothing was left oh nothing
like I already been smart about it dude
like uh the safety pin was left or
whatever was in there yeah so damn yeah
it's crazy but when it hits it hits baby
it's so good keep trying yeah don't give
up don't give up on your dreams
[Music]
laughs